وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال وزير خارجيه
السويد توبياس ان روسيا ستهزم اوكرانيا او
ستهزم في اوكرانيا وان بلاده تنسق مع
الدول الحلفاء لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
قريب لكنه اشار الى ان عدد الدبابات التي
سترسل ما يزال في اطار السريه في الوقت
الحالي كما اضاف المسؤول السويديه ان
بلاده تنتظر تصديق تركيا والمجر على
انضمامها في وقت قريب
قررنا بعد الحرب والغزو الشامل لروسيا على
اوكرانيا قبل عام ان ننضم الى النيتو
لننهي 200 عام من سياسه عدم الانحياز هناك
الان 28 من اصل 30 من دول النيتو صدقت على
انضمام السويد وفنلندا باستثناء المجر
وتركيا ننتظر قرار البرلمان المجري
الاسبوع
وايضا تركيا التي وقعنا معها مذكره تفاهم
وقد التزمت بلادنا بكل ما تم الاتفاق عليه
بالمذكره ونعتقد ان الوقت حان ليصدق
البرلمان التركي على انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى الحلف